[Music]
that's right five seconds of summer is
back with a brand new single off their
upcoming album and the guys luke michael
ashton and callum join us now what's up
fellas hey how are you doing thanks for
having us congratulations complete mess
is the new single so nice of you guys to
write a song about me
no i mean obviously this is an amazing
kind of evolution of the band talk to me
about the inspiration behind the new
track okay so
you want the real details
yeah so in the middle of the
pandemic i guess we're still in one
in the thick of it um the band sort of
uh realized we needed to get away and
sort of go to somewhere remote so we
went to joshua tree um classic story and
we went out there and just sort of
wanted to be by ourselves and isolated
and see what would happen if we make
music great if we you know just hang as
mates and that's also a win um and we
ended up making this song and a few
other ones but this was the one that
came like honestly it was one of the
first ones we did out there and it's
stood the test of time over the last
year year and a half and it's been
amazing we love this song we love the
way it feels and the way it sums up the
whole album um musically and lyrically
yeah it's really it's really like
this song specifically is so personal to
us because it's kind of the first song
that we've all you know just written on
our own and like we self-produced and
kind of like we're really taking
ownership and like
pride into
kind of our
you know this new step for us which is
sort of like scary but really exciting
as you mentioned there's a lot that
happened since your last record i mean
the lockdown and the pandemic a couple
of you guys put out some solo records
and stuff like that but how would you
describe you know this next era of five
stars and how it compares to your
previous work i think overall for us it
feels like almost like the first album
again we work for ten years like on our
songwriting and uh well not the last two
years but playing live and being like
the best band we can be
and particularly diving into like
michael producing this album it's been
like such an amazing journey of like
learning stuff and doing it in a way
where it's just the four of us for a lot
of the album it's been
um it just feels a little bit more i
guess for lack of better words like very
free and like yeah it feels beautiful to
be honest and personal i'm sure it's
definitely personal very introspective
we had a lot of time
obviously everyone had some time at home
um to sort of i don't know dive through
things internally and think talking
through that as a band it was really
it's really in the music this is the
first song entirely written and produced
by y'all what was that experience like
and how did it challenge you i think
the best part about making this new you
know
complete mess but also a lot of these
other songs that we've made that we also
haven't released yet but
we sort of really trusted each other and
we trusted each other's musical ability
and kind of our musical intuition and
you know we really
you know
it's just it's kind of crazy and and
like
in in a way without you know going too
much into it but like we really have
faith in each other and we really like
you know believe in each other's
songwriting and our ability as
artists so i think that that to me was
like the most
like
the like greatest part about
all of this music that we've made is
like we're so proud of each other in how
we've grown and sort of the the type of
thing that we want to create together
and sort of we're able to you know with
complete mess especially like articulate
the exact band that we are now and like
you know it's so like it resonates so
deeply within us and we just kind of you
know hope that other people understand
that and see it and it resonates with
them too were you able to take a step
back and realize wow we have actually
accomplished not only a lot together but
we've grown together too have you felt
that like i i feel like you know you
can't predict how the bond will evolve
with the music right but clearly you
guys are closer than ever yeah i think
it's also pretty special to be in a band
i mean i i experience it every day you
know
it's it's a special connection when you
know everyone gives each other space to
be free within their creative expression
um and also a band that always works to
be better at communicating um and that's
you know a quality that will keep us
around for a long time
so due to longevity right no exactly and
yeah and i think it's just important for
people to know like a lot of work goes
into
the dynamics of this band and absolutely
um i think we're just more passionate
than ever to um create some good for
people absolutely well here's what i
want to know when you guys have had
moments of being a complete mess how did
you get through it you know what's the
secret there oh geez man i mean i'm the
drummer obviously uh drum therapy is key
and i've been thinking about opening a
store on uh you know whatever it is
yeah i remember like roomba
yeah i was like thinking about zumba
classical yeah i was thinking something
like that but we always like turn it
around we go okay we have an opportunity
to put our lives onto paper
into a song
and be expressive in that way and it's
kind of therapy so you know having this
band in in in you know adult life is
just incredible it's a place to share
it's a place to work it out how are you
guys when you're a complete mess what
kind of pulls you out of there well i
might have to go to this drum therapy
thing that
right
sign us up man this has changed but i
think
i don't know just having time to even
digest all of it and like understand
that we have been a band for 10 years
and how awesome that is that we're still
here in my trip
a decade you guys have been together
you've been five sauce for 10 years yeah
and you know what like being in a band
is like being married and i know you say
that thinking that when we were
explaining like communication like and
like honesty and stuff it's like we've
been married for 10 years now trust yeah
like everything you have to put in some
work right yeah
does it feel like 10 years has passed so
it feels like 10 years has passed but it
feels like for some reason i want to do
it for another 10. okay you know it's
it's kind of just like um it's like wow
you know the more people we share our
music with the more connectivity we
create through our music it's just
really inspiring to be alive and to be
able to do this and and do this thing
you know and speaking of connection you
guys are going to hit the road again
soon how excited are you to like
interact with your fans go back on tour
i was lucky enough to see you guys live
and you shred love that yeah we do shred
you do you guys put on quite the show
but how excited are you guys to go on
tour oh yeah we're ready it's kind of
like you know we haven't done it in a
couple years and we're getting i
wouldn't say rusty but
we're getting rusty
i'm starting to think okay we better you
know get this show on the road hopefully
yeah so yeah yeah i know your fans are
ready they're like so ready to see you
guys they're like they're already
pitching what cities you guys need to
hit i know yeah right like we'll come to
any they should at this point we're like
just let us know they should organize
our tours
i love it before i let you go luke all
right one of your latest tick tock
videos has fans buzzing when you marry
the girl that wrote this banger little
do you know
i'm breaking while you fall asleep so i
have to ask are you married or what i've
never heard anyone say that you ticked
off
my tick tock's buzzin
people think you're married what say you
no i miss i meant marry in the future
right but i didn't it's the the
voiceover thing on tiktok that i've only
just figured out how to use uh it's
confusing it's very confusing was there
and i couldn't change it and it was
supposed to be like going to mary okay
so were you married or what right
i gotta say he's got a lot of rings on
his fingers
i don't think that's a wedding band do
you know i don't know
all right you guys congratulations on
complete mess i can't wait to see you
back on the road and the full album man
what do you want fans to know about it
in one word who's got a good word
immersion ooh
there you have it folks all right five
seconds of summer thank you guys so much
for being here we appreciate you thanks
for having us absolutely
[Music]